new documentary series shows the raw an
emotional toll on monica lewinsky of her
affair with former President Bill
Clinton Winsky is more forthright than
she has been in years about her
relationship with President Clinton the
series called the Clinton affair
premieres Sunday on A&E
Tony Tecopa is in Washington with what
we're learning from the former White
House intern Tony good morning good
morning Monica Lewinsky says the most
painful and traumatic experiences of her
life followed her affair with former
President Clinton and if she could she
would erase all those from her memory
instead she's revisiting those years
hoping to find a better way forward for
the country and for herself I was
terrified
it's an emotional look behind the mask
of someone who stood stoic in the public
eye for decades
I hoped a hurtful I was Monica Lewinsky
spoke to A&E about her affair with
President Clinton's from the highs bill
happened to be standing there and he
motioned me in
I don't think my heart had ever beat as
fast to the lowest lows as she was
confronted by FBI agents about the
affair I remember looking out the window
and thinking that the only way to fix
this was to kill myself forced to jump
out the window
[Music]
was gonna do to my family in a Vanity
Fair piece about why she participated in
the docu-series Lewinsky rights she
feels grief for the broken young woman
who watched the president deny the
affair I did not have sexual relations
with that woman this year in the wake of
the me2 movement Clinton struggled with
the question of whether he should
apologize to Lewinsky you didn't
apologize to her I have not talked to
her the suggestion was that I never
apologized I did former First Lady
Hillary Clinton told CBS last month that
President Clinton should not have
stepped down after the affair became
public there are people who look at the
incidents of the 90s and they say a
President of the United States cannot
have a consensual relationship with an
intern the power imbalances too was an
adult but let me ask you this where's
the investigation of the current
incumbent against whom numerous
allegations have been made and which he
dismisses denies and ridicules so there
was an investigation and it as I believe
came out in the right place Lewinsky for
her part is focused on healing from the
memories of that traumatic time however
wrong it was however misguided for who I
was in that very moment at 22 years old
that was how it felt now we reached out
to the Clintons and have not heard back
Lewinsky for her part says which she now
feels is grief grief for the year she
lost and grief for the pain that the
affair caused others now this is
interesting in fact as part of her own
healing process she says if she saw
Hillary Clinton today she would
apologize Gail
alright Tony I guess this Hillary
Clinton would not be interested in
hearing an apology for Monica at this
time but my heart goes out to Monica
because this this affair has really
defined her whole life and everyone has
moved forward and she still seems to
have a taint or a Scarlet Letter on her
which I don't think is fair and you
still say the emotions she grapples yeah
he talks about it yeah it's good that
she can finally tell her story in the
way she wants to do that think about the
grief that she talks about yes the pain
from the annoyance of that relationship
abuse that she suffered and that's still
real it lives with you for your life
your entire life and that everybody
needs to wake up to that and I'm glad
she's talking I am to him too